because there's an idea there's I don't
know if you guys agree with this or not
but there's an idea in the men's online
you know advice space that basically
women look for two different things they
look for the dads and they look for the
cats so they look for the guys who are
more like the provider guys more he's a
nice guy he's Dependable he's solid he's
got a good picture
and then you've got the sexy the sexy
dude over here who maybe hasn't got any
of that stuff but he's ripped and he's
like Devil May care and he's like he
does you know he's that kind of yeah and
and there's this idea that women look
for those two things so what he sounds
like you're saying is that on the birth
control they go for the first and then
they come with the birth control they're
like right where's Chad yeah
where's the pool boy